[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMRAT SAHA: A bit about me.
So I'm Sam.
I'm based out of Milwaukee.
And I'm a customer
engineer with Google Cloud.
And my main client is Kohl's,
which is one of the reasons why
I'm speaking Kohl's.
And just a simple
fact about Milwaukee.
I was driving on
Monday, and on the radio
they actually said
Milwaukee hadn't
reached 70 degrees
Fahrenheit for 180 days.
So that gives an indication
as to how cold that place is.
I just thought I should
share that with you.
So yeah, so EDW
Migration Journey.
I need help.
So a couple of quick
things before we get
started because
I'm going to forget
to say this at the end of it.
At the end of the session,
if you have questions,
please come up to
the microphone right
here so we can all hear you.
And the second is, there's
also a survey that we
would love for you to fill out.
So if you could do
that after the session,
that would be much appreciated.
So the problem statement,
why are we here today?
We are trying to
talk about how do you
take your data
warehouse, you know,
on-prem, and move to the
cloud with minimal disruption,
make sure you still
have security,
and make sure that
all your teams get
as productive as possible
as quickly as possible?
So there's certain
elements of this.
And obviously, this is not
going to hold for everybody.
But there's certain broad
strokes you can look at.
So for instance, you have to
look at speed of adoption.
And one of the key
things is that if you
have a bunch of
people sitting around,
and things go
offline, well, it can
cause significant
disruptions to your business.
So can we get this up quickly?
Can you get it running quickly?
And can they be productive
as quickly as possible?
Then scale, how do
you scale as needed?
How do you scale elastically?
So as I mentioned,
Kohl's is my customer.
So in the retail space, you have
a certain seasonality of data.
You have a certain
seasonality of needs of data.
And can your data warehouse
help you manage that?
In other words, can you
scale appropriately?
And that's really
important because you also
have to maintain--
not only should you
be productive with the
data, but you should also
be able to manage your costs.
Insights and
Analysis, how quickly
can you-- because when
you're moving your data
warehouse from
on-prem to cloud, will
your sudden processes
already in place
to help you be productive
with that data?
So can you move those workloads
over quickly, efficiently,
and make sure that you can also
empower new kinds of workloads?
So something more modern comes
along, or something more--
let's say you are diving
into the AI space.
Can your new data warehouse help
you deliver on those workloads?
And security is paramount.
So you want to make sure that
only people who have access
to the data should have
access to the data.
You want to make sure that
the needs of your end users
also are met.
So privacy is maintained.
And these are the
broad strokes when
it comes to what you need to
consider when moving your data
warehouse, say, to the cloud.
So most of you are
here in the room
because you probably
have some, at least,
familiarity with
how an EDW works.
So this is more of a-- this
is sort of a level set.
What is a data warehouse?
The easiest way to think
of a data warehouse
is think of it as your
central repository
where you can just dump
a whole bunch of data
in so that you can derive
insights out of it.
Now, what it means in
terms of the particular,
will differ from
system to system.
But, in general, that's the
intent of a data warehouse.
Who is it meant to serve?
Well, that depends
on your organization.
But in general, you have
a bunch of analysts,
you have business leaders.
You have people
of differing needs
who need to get insights
out of the data.
Was it it suppose to enable?
Well, fundamentally, it's
a driver of business.
That's the key requirement
of collecting the data
and analyzing the data
in the first place.
So you cannot keep--
that is one of the
first things that you've
got to keep in mind is
that how do you enable
business decisions to be made?
And what it can
look like, so I've
got in a bunch of arguments
with a whole bunch
of people about what does a--
what is a representative
slide for this?
So none of us could decide
as to a common theme,
so we decided, you know what,
let's go the magic of Wikipedia
where are a whole bunch of
other people can argue about it,
and come up with something
that is rather simple.
As you can see, you've
got a bunch of data
on the left-hand side.
It gets in the staging kind
of area, and gets ingested.
And you have
different data mods,
which are aligned to
specific business needs.
And you have different purposes
that those data mods in turn
could serve.
So it's, again,
large volumes of data
that you wrangle, get
it into a central area,
and now that can
be piped through--
to serve different
business needs,
and different people can gain
different insights out of it,
make different business
decisions out of it.
So now, we talked about
just what an EDW is.
And one of the big
reasons that we
are talking about why do you
want to move to the cloud,
well, there's some
reasons for it.
Because if there weren't
any issues or challenges,
you wouldn't need to do the
migration in the first place.
So, one of the
first things that we
have to deal with
in today's world
is that the amount of
data and the kinds of data
you're dealing with
is rapidly changing.
So not only do you
have to accommodate
for the amount of
data, but the kinds
of data, and the speed
at which it's ingested.
Now, one way of handling
this is sort of provision
on your data warehouse.
This is where the
seasonality of the data
actually has a
significant impact.
Because if you over-scale
to handle the spikes,
well, now you're stuck with
a bunch of infrastructure
sitting around that
is underutilized
most of the time,
which is not efficient.
The other way is
you under-provision,
and say, let's just
ignore the spikes.
And that's not going
to work, either.
Is it responsive to the needs?
How does it adapt?
As you have more and more
people coming in, say,
with different ideas, and
they want to try out stuff,
can your data warehouse
accommodate their needs
as well?
Can it be faster?
Can you produce your reports
faster so that people
can make decisions faster?
Different kinds of workloads,
so in some cases, your--
let's say that you're doing a
bunch of aggregate analysis,
great.
But in some cases, say you want
to create a new data set out
of it that is more suitable
towards, say, machine learning.
So, can it actually
accommodate that?
The other thing that
I've seen in the field
is just that it's a
victim of its own success.
When you bring all the
data in, you go in,
and you make this
significant investment,
and now you have this central
repository that is enabling
all these business decisions.
Well, the expectation is that it
continues to do that over time.
And now suddenly, two years
down the road, you say,
we need more
capacity, or we need--
it's no longer providing
the kind of results
that we are used to.
So it's almost as if it
was transformational.
But because now the
expectation's so high,
it's hard to keep up, especially
in a staticky kind of setup
that a traditional
on-prem is going to be.
And then-- which goes
to can it meet our needs
two, three five years from now?
Are you going to have
the same conversations
over and over again with
your business leaders saying,
oh, we need more capacity?
Or we can't run these
workloads, we can't--
can it still deliver over time?
And so these are some
of the common refrains
that we see in the field
all the time, which
is why I would like to now
bring in Jas from Kohl's, who
went through this in real life.
JASVINDER SINGH:
So, thank you Sam.
First of all, my introduction.
I am Jasvinder Singh.
I'm a senior manager of big
data analytics at Kohl's.
And thank you,
Sam, for reminding
that we have to go back
to the 40-degree weather
after enjoying the
70-degree weather over here.
So in most of the enterprises,
the analytical ecosystem
has been built over
past several years.
And over the years, we have
collected different systems.
And more recently in
the last few years,
most of the companies have
also added big data and Hadoop
to their ecosystem.
So let's talk about why did
we even need so many systems
to start with?
So the main factor was cost.
So as we brought in
these technical stacks,
and they had kind
of fixed capacity.
So based on the cost and
based on our use cases,
we bought some fixed capacity.
And as we started working
through the years,
the capacity was not
enough because we
needed to solve more
and more use cases.
and so we ended up bringing more
of these monolithic solutions.
And some of those solutions
that were brought in
were for our technical
capabilities,
some of the use cases
needed a different system
to be brought in.
So at the end of
the day, we had data
coming in from
our source systems
and landing into different
warehousing systems.
And since we could not bring
data into a single system,
we basically had the
need of exchanging data
between the systems,
so a lot of data
was being copied
across these systems.
And at the end of the
day, we had basically
arrows going in every
direction that you can imagine.
So just to highlight what
are the issues that we deal
with with an
architecture like this,
we had disparate data
sources for enterprise use.
We had inconsistent analysis.
And decisions were inconsistent
because the data was
in different systems, and as
it was copied from one system
to another system, some
of the data quality things
were also having issues with.
It was difficult
to access the data
across different platforms.
So let's say you needed data
from two of the systems,
and I have to build a report.
The only way I could
do that is basically
copy the data from one
system to other system.
And also it was very difficult
to understand the other level
data within these systems.
And if you're
looking for data, it
was kind of a scavenger hunt.
And there is very few people
in the enterprise who know
where to get the data from.
And the other
problem that we were
having was that there was
no common understanding
of the definitions and the
measurements of the data
within the warehousing systems.
So overall, we had
a big opportunity
that we could basically
go for and solve it
in our future use cases.
So, in our traditional
warehousing system,
we have these characteristics
that are limitations.
So you can see on
the left-hand side,
we had to-- as we brought
in data into our ecosystem,
we had to structure it first.
And the reason we had
to structure it first is
because we cannot just bring
in anything and everything,
and the reason being it is
basically fixed capacity.
So there was a lot of time
spent upfront to structure
the data before we
ingested it and brought it
for the analytical purposes.
And over the years,
as I said, we
brought these monolithic stacks.
And as we are working
through different use cases,
one stack would not
solve the problem.
So we had to bring
in some other stack
to solve the newer use cases.
So at the end of
the day, we had--
some of our challenges
on-prem were
we had a very complex
operations in our data centers.
We had these multiple stacks
which were just talking
to each other, exchanging data.
And it was becoming
more complex for us
to support in our data center.
And even with all of
these different stacks,
it was very difficult to
keep up with the data growth.
So our new approach,
or the new way
of delivering the
warehouse, is that we
are going with a
flexible structure
where we can get in
any kind of data.
So we can basically
get in structured data,
semi-structured, or
unstructured data,
and we can ingest it, and then
analyze it, and then structure
it based on our needs.
And the ecosystem will
be of dynamic capacities,
or we can add
capacity as needed.
And it is an ecosystem
which is enabled
by the bunch of services which
can basically solve all our use
cases rather than just
moving the data from one
system to other system.
So in terms of
advantages, we basically
had a faster speed to market.
We basically enabled
a bunch of services,
and we were able
to quickly stand
up and deliver some value.
Our new approach is
elastic and also managed
so that we don't
have to deal with
all these complex
infrastructure operations.
So here is how we
are planning to build
the single source of truth
in the Google Cloud BigQuery.
So this is basically Kohl's
data lake in BigQuery.
So as you can see, we
have different systems
on the left-hand side,
similar to what we had before.
And we have data coming in.
It can be any kind
of data, whether it's
a batch or real-time.
And we are assembling all of
the data in Google BigQuery,
and then making the
data available for all
of our use cases here.
So some of the benefits of using
an architecture like this is we
have basically a
single source of truth.
And all the analytical use
cases are driving the value
from the single
warehouse in BigQuery.
So also using this architecture,
we have enabled self-service.
So we have provided
the decision makers
with easy access and
readily-available data
which is secure and clean.
Along with clean data, we have
provided our business users
with some data discovery
and visualization
tools, which will help them
with speeding up the decision
process.
And since the team is not busy
with just copying the data
from one system to
other system, we
have started focusing on some
of the advanced analytics.
We have started-- shifted
from structured reporting
to kind of more
actionable insights
and predictive analytics.
And since, as you can see, the
data is in the single system,
we are now standardizing
the business metadata,
and the attributes,
and the metrics
across the organization.
So our approach for building
this has been very simple.
So we have been building a
parallel environment in Google
by channeling all of
our existing sources
that are going into the
traditional warehouse today
and channeling them
to go into BigQuery.
So as we bring and land all
of the data into BigQuery,
we are working with
our business partners
and prioritizing how they
would like to cleanse and start
using the data within BigQuery.
So I think-- so as
we bring the data,
and we cleanse it,
make it available,
we have started to
solve certain use
cases that were being solved
with our previous solution
as well.
But now we are able to
solve some other use
cases which totally
needed a different stack.
Marketing operations is
also leveraging this stack,
and also recommendations can
also leverage this stack.
And as we are
delivering the data,
we are also doing
some comparison
between on-prem and cloud.
And we have tools that we have
built to showcase that the data
which we are--
which we are assembling in
BigQuery is higher quality,
and also it is delivered
with lesser amount of time.
And it can be leveraged for
analytics plus other use cases
as well.
So here is the logical
architecture slide
that we have been using.
So going from bottom
to the top, we
have different sources
of data coming in.
We have external
data sources, and we
have internal data sources.
So we are landing the data
using either file transports,
or reading real time but Plume,
or getting it into Kafka.
And we are landing
all of the data
into a BigQuery
staging area where
we are applying some
transformation logic, some
of the business
logic, and making
the data available in
the certified data sets.
And in some cases, we might
be creating some enterprise
reporting structures
which are being
leveraged by the
different reporting tools.
So I think the key thing
here is that all of this
is being done in BigQuery.
So we are not really
leveraging a lot of other tools
to deliver the data.
Although you can see that we do
have a little bit of Dataproc.
And that is being leveraged for
some advanced transformation
use cases or certain
use cases where
we have to protect
the data differently.
So we do have some
Dataproc and Spark
that we are leveraging for that.
But generally speaking, those
use cases are less than 5%.
So using this architecture,
we are basically
enabling faster access
to the data for Kohl's
analytical communities.
We have increased the
speed and efficiency
of the data delivery.
And also since it is a
single kind of a stack,
it is very easy to
facilitate the governance
and ensure the data quality.
And we are using data security
using some of the encryption
that BigQuery provides,
and also managing access
using the fine-grained access
control that are in BigQuery.
So overall, this is
standardizing the data
architecture across Kohl's
analytical communities.
So at a high level,
the data that we
are bringing into our warehouse
is primarily real-time sources,
or it is the bad sources
that are coming in.
So in case of the bad
sources, we basically
land the data in Google
Storage in the raw state.
And as I discussed
in my previous slide,
most of the data can
directly go into BigQuery.
And in some cases, we
are using some Spark,
and it's a lightweight
application,
which can help it with certain
PII elements protection,
converting the formats
if the formats are not
ready for BigQuery,
or converting it
to a different file format.
So once the data
is loaded into raw,
and you can see a similar
pipeline on the top
where we have streaming data
coming in from the sources,
whether they are
read through APIs,
or these are pushed into our
Kafka kind of infrastructure,
and we have a Spark
streaming application which
is using the BigQuery
streaming API
and landing the data in raw in
a streaming fashion in BigQuery.
So once the data
is all in the raw,
we are combining the data set,
creating the gold structures
or the certified data sets.
And once the data is available
in the gold data sets,
it is available for
different use cases,
whether it is the data
scientists who are basically
pulling the data using
some BiSpark jobs,
using BQ's storage APIs.
Or we have extracts that are
being run through a Spark job,
or there are some
reporting use cases which
we are enabling on Tableau,
and all the Ad-Hoc analytics
is basically
happening on BigQuery.
So to summarize here,
so this talks about some
of the challenges
that we were having
with our on-prem solution.
So we have-- like with our
current on-prem solution, where
we Hadoop and we had
[INAUDIBLE] systems,
we had very complex operations.
And then that-- and
also with that kind
of complex operations,
we were unable to keep up
with the data growth.
And we were having
issues with data
latency due to the data
moving across various systems.
We had a very complex
implementation.
Since we had kind of
a zoo of technologies
and no common approaches, it was
very difficult to just manage
the ecosystem.
Data was hard to understand.
And the data was--
the data quality was
suffering because it was
going through multiple hops.
And the data existed
in multiple systems.
And our infrastructure
cost was really high
because there was lot of
duplication that was happening.
So the advantages of doing this
in the cloud BigQuery ecosystem
is that we don't have
any upfront cost.
And as we need--
as we are adding more
and more to BigQuery,
we are adding more capacity to
our BigQuery infrastructure.
And it is-- so we leverage
the fixed slots within Kohl's.
So we started off with a
certain number of slots.
And as we are growing,
storage is not a problem.
But as we need more
and more compute,
we are working with
our Google, and we
are able to bring in
more slots as needed.
So it's a faster speed
to market because
of usage of the cloud services.
And also as we are
bringing in data,
we have created some reusable
components and functions
that can help with file
management or auditing.
So those are kind
of-- just everything
is a template for us.
So as we bring in
more and more data,
we just use a standard template,
and we bring in all the data.
And some of those standard
functions are being used.
The solution is elastic from
both compute and storage
standpoint.
And it is hosted by Google.
So with that, I bring Sam
back to the podium again.
Thank you, Sam.
SAMRAT SAHA: Hello?
All right.
So thanks, Jas.
As you can see, he has
the breadth and depth
of expertise in
managing data at scale
for a really large retailer.
And I've been fortunate to
be part of that journey.
And I've seen how
complex it can be.
Sometimes it can
be overwhelming.
You have tons of
different moving parts,
and you have something
already in place.
So the ante's
really high, right,
is that you're going from
something that's functional--
yes, you may not be
extremely satisfied with it--
and you're trying
to move all of that
to a completely different
system altogether
without disrupting business.
So this is why I say,
what just happened,
because there was a lot
of moving parts there.
And in my experience with
working with Jas and his team,
how do you take a
monumental task like this?
And in our discussions, he
had a very insightful way
of discussing it
or describing it.
This is a generational event.
It doesn't happen all the time.
So when you are
there, this is not--
this is going to be a
"once in a generation"
event that you're going to take
something, your existing data
warehouse, and move
it to the cloud.
So it is complex, and you have
a lot of different people.
And you have to get buy-in
from a whole bunch of people.
How do you manage that?
Obviously, leverage
accounting, this
is where people like me come in.
We can help out.
If nothing else, when
you get frustrated,
you can just yell at me.
That's cool.
But it comes down to this.
The first thing is you
have to decide to move.
It is a decision that has to--
you have to be firm about it.
It's not a wishy-washy thing.
Let's go for it.
You have to get
stakeholder buy-in.
That's one of the--
in a complex
transformation like this,
you need to get buy-in
across the board.
So that is key.
Then one of the things
that I saw Jas' team do
is you go through diligently and
identify all the data sources,
auditing it, making sure
that they all make sense,
figuring out what is it going
to look like in, say, BigQuery
because they use BigQuery as
the central pillar of their data
strategy going forward.
Then the simplest thing
is identify a chunk.
Go the POC route so that
you can get-- first of all,
it allows your team
to get comfortable
with the new semantics, the new
technology, the new paradigms
that are involved in
BigQuery, and build upon it.
It allows you to re-imagine
what your data warehouse is
going to be in Google Cloud.
And obviously, execute.
And I've seen them execute
on this, and flawlessly.
It has been complex.
But his team has done
an awesome job on this.
So in one of the
previous slides,
I said, what are the
broad strokes that you
need to consider when
you are moving your data
warehouse to the cloud?
That was speed of adoption.
So this is BigQuery.
This is our solution to help
you be data informed at scale.
So speed of adoption,
BigQuery, you
can get up and
running very quickly.
If your analysts are very
comfortable using SQL,
go for it.
It's available for you.
As Jas just mentioned,
scaling as needed.
So they started off with
a bunch of fixed slots,
and as their capacity
needs started increasing,
they started increasing
the number of slots
available to them.
So they could scale as needed.
Insights analysis,
again, they moved over
some of the existing scripts,
some of the existing workloads,
and were productive as
quickly as possible.
And they also unlocked
more workloads.
And they were able to
deliver on this faster
over much more amounts of data.
And it's also opening
up-- and there's
an article on
BigQuery, is that ML is
going more and more important.
So BQML, if you're
not familiar with it,
I would highly recommend
looking into it.
It allows you to execute machine
learning models on BigQuery
itself, which is pretty cool.
And security, encryption
at rest, in flight,
and you've got very fine-grained
access controls using IAM.
And with this-- some
customers go ahead
and do it on their own.
They have their deep expertise.
Their teams are built out.
They can actually pull
this on their own.
And sometimes, you
need additional help.
And this is why at
GCP we allow you--
we try to help you
figure out what is
the best approach you can take.
And sometimes, you
need a partner.
And this is where I will
look introduce Dr. Phil, who
is the president of Datametica.
PHIL SHELLEY: Thanks Sam.
Thanks Jas, too.
So let's get into
migrating data warehouses.
So why move to GCP?
You've already
covered a lot of that.
There's some very good reasons
to move analytics workload
to GCP.
It's the best in
class in our view.
BQ is a killer app.
And I think many of you
know about it already.
But moving a large
data warehouse
has some risks and
challenges to the business.
The business can be
clearly severely damaged.
If you scrub the migration
of a data warehouse,
you're going to know
about it pretty quickly.
So we started years ago
moving these things manually.
But you take a large,
complex data warehouse
or an infrastructure
like Jas presented,
it's extremely
complex to understand
the data flows, contingencies,
their interdependencies.
And to move that
manually is risky
because you can
move a little piece
and then break the rest
of it in the process.
So we started to figure
out how do we move this
in a more automated fashion
quite a few years ago, and then
how do we actually manage--
this is a wordy slide.
Sorry about it's so wordy.
But you can take
your time to read it.
But really the reason
to go to slide--
to cloud is the
unlimited scalability,
the flexibility of
performance you get,
the ability to bring in all
the different data sets--
streaming, real-time,
IoT, batch,
and structured, unstructured
in any sequence,
any format you want, and the
speed of latency that you need.
And putting all your data
in a single point of truth,
there's no question, we all know
that's logical, sensible, very
helpful, and is definitely the
direction that we're all going.
The fast pace of
features that are
being added you see constantly,
or the announcements at NEXT,
here, new features coming
all the time, there's
no way you can--
anyone else can compete
with the speed of cloud vendors'
innovation at the moment.
And the new capabilities
are coming every few weeks.
And because you're
on one platform
now with the data in a
single point of truth place,
you can start to adopt those
tools as they come along.
And then you can
focus, as Jas said,
you can focus more on the
actual workload innovation.
How do you drive
value from the data,
rather than worrying
about running
servers, headaches of
data centers blowing up
in the middle of the night,
which Keith and I had
a few years ago.
It's just getting you
out of that headache
and focusing on the
value from your data
and adopt these new
tools as they come.
So cost is a big play.
So you're starting to talk
about large tower data
appliances of $20 million
plus each, in some cases
five to six years life, 20%
annual maintenance on top
of that, massive costs
of buying and acquiring,
and then all the
people to run that.
So the cost advantages
of moving to cloud
are pretty significant.
We often do cost
calculations for companies
early on to show
the cost benefit.
And in the larger data
warehouses, we see up to 60%--
almost 70% in some cases
five-year cost savings.
Even in the small ones, we
see 20% to 30% cost savings.
So going to cloud
is very powerful.
And I'm going to come back
on that in a little while.
And then you pay for
what you use, of course.
Also we want to eliminate
a lot of this legacy ETL.
We've had ETL around for 30
years or more in some cases.
It's very batch-wise thinking.
It's not the modern way
of dealing with data.
IoT, streaming,
Jas mentioned that.
The way we're going is
real-time enterprise.
Streaming is happening.
It's something we have to
embrace because the old ETL
mentality is really
holding us back.
So we want to eliminate a lot
of legacy ETL at the same time,
and we want to be
more labor efficient.
So common challenges
when you want
to move a data warehouse so that
you have to address internally
is budget and cost, of course.
It's going to cost
something to move.
You will be paid back within
a year, or two, or three.
At most typically you
will see a payback.
Sometimes even in a single
year, you'll see payback.
Especially if your data
where house is end of life.
If it's about to be
end-of-life, the ROI on moving
is very powerful, usually
less than a year of payback.
So how did you get started?
What are the steps?
How did you get your data there?
Not only how did you
get the data there,
but how do you keep
it synchronized?
Because this is a moving train.
Your existing system is live.
There's data flowing
all the time.
It's changing.
So you can't just
take a snapshot
and move it and
expect it to work.
It doesn't work like that.
So how did you move
it all, and how do you
keep it all synchronized?
And it can take years to do this
because nobody has the patients
to do a big multi-year
project anymore.
It has to take weeks and months.
So those are the
challenges you'll see.
So we started to develop years
ago some tools around that.
First of all, how
do you assess--
how do you plan and assess this?
I can-- if you all here
have a data warehouse,
I can pretty much guarantee you
don't know everything that's
running on your data warehouse.
There are jobs--
ETL jobs, transformation
jobs, user jobs.
There's data being adjusted.
I can promise you you
don't know and you have not
documented everything that's
running on your system.
So how can you move it if you
don't know what's running?
So we developed a tool.
It's a machine learning-based
tool that discovers everything,
I mean, literally
everything that's
running on an environment, so
in a very fine-grained detail.
And then it uses the
clustering algorithm
to cluster pieces
of workload together
so you can move a cluster
at a time in a sprint model.
The next piece is how do
you convert all the code?
You can't just typically
lift and shift a code base
from a data warehouse.
So if you took Teradata, it may
have M loads, it may have SQL.
For users it might
have BTEQ scripts,
it might have ETL scripts
that are non-standard SQL.
And then you're going to
put them onto BQ to run,
or on Spark, or
whatever on cloud.
They have to be
converted in some cases.
So rarely can you--
almost never can
you lift and shift
a data warehouse
with all of the workload
without some conversion.
So how do you automate
that conversion?
How would you convert
different dialects of SQL
to a standardized
BQ SQL or Spark SQL?
So again, we have
to automate that.
Then how do you move the data?
So how did you move--
how did you replace that ETL?
How do you replace
the data pipelines?
How do we make that a more
seamless parametrically-driven
exercise?
And finally, how do
you validate the data?
As you in transition,
you've got data
in one data warehouse
that's a live system,
you've now got data
in cloud, and you've
got to run in parallel
for a period of time
because you need to know
those two systems match.
You need to know that your
new system is giving you
exactly the same results
as the old system.
With the same data
inputs, you're
getting the same data
outputs because your business
users won't let you switch over
until each phase is validated.
So validation is
a huge challenge.
So we have automated
that as well.
So combining those tools, we can
now do a sprint-based approach.
We can now break a
data warehouse down
into many small sprints where we
can run each sprint in parallel
on both systems for
a period of time,
and only move those users
over for that sprint
when we are confident that
both systems are matching.
The data's matching, the
queries are matching,
the outputs a matching,
and performance is
at least matching.
And so when we've
done that, we can
move it, and move the next
sprint, and the next sprint.
So it's not a big-bang
lift and shift anymore
because that's way too
difficult, too scary.
We want to break it
down into sprints.
And now we can do that.
Now costs, are
they really lower?
People ask that.
Hadoop was pretty cheap
for storage on-premise.
But, of course, we're
now dealing with storage
on cloud between $0.01 and
$0.03 per gigabyte per month,
and getting lower all the time.
And that is impossible to
match with any on-site storage
that I know of.
The separation of
compute and storage,
so we now have storage
that's very low cost.
We can bring different
computer engines.
We can bring BQ, we can bring
Spark, we can bring Python,
we can bring whatever
computer engines
we want to the same copy of
data on the same storage,
and the storage is low cost.
So there are significant cost
savings in a well-structured--
like Jas' new architecture is
a perfect example of a very
clean, simple architecture,
single point of truth,
under the low-cost storage,
and bringing any compute engine
to that that you need.
And that's the way to go.
So the promises to
take the frustration
and cost out of these
migrations and the anxiety
of these large migrations.
So you may have thousands--
well, you will have,
in some cases, many thousands
of users using these legacy
systems.
We have to move them
without all the anxiety.
And that's why we
approach this in this sort
of sprint-wise process.
So we want to optimize it.
We want to automate it.
We want to use the tools to
do the conversion of code.
We want to do the
automated tools
for doing the validation
and the data migration.
At right at the bottom, we
want to run in parallel,
reduce risk, and
errors and mistakes.
That is the only way we know of
moving these large environments
successfully.
So the targets of this
level of automation
are here on the right,
clearly a lot of Teradata.
The Teradata is the most
expensive, of course,
data warehouse.
And moving that has the
biggest ROI of all of them.
Netezza, if you're
a Netezza customer,
you know that IBM has
end-of-life support,
a whole a lot of Netezza
machines at the moment.
There's a lot of people are
wanting to move Netezza.
Oracle, of course,
and Hadoop are still--
as Jas mentioned,
there's a lot of Hadoop
that needs to be moved, and
even the old DB2 and Greenplum.
So there's a lot of these
tools have been written
to automate the migration
of these to cloud
and all the associated
pieces of ETL.
So the time efficiency
now, through automation,
we're seeing about a 2/3
reduction in cost and time.
Time particularly because we
can automate a lot of this,
automate the assessment,
automate the migration,
automate the
validation, and do it
in a sprint-wise
process in about 50%
cost saving or a
little more sometimes.
So now we can move
things quicker
and see the benefits that you
saw from the Kohl's example.
So we're going to do
some Q&A in a minute.
I think, though, Sam you want
to come back for a minute?
SAMRAT SAHA: Thank you.
Yeah, so thanks, Dr. Phil.
As you can see that
when we started off,
we talked about a
customer who was
able to deliver on their own.
And sometimes you
need a partner.
Some of the key points that
stood out in what Dr. Phil just
said, one is automation.
A lot of this is
dependent on automation.
Can you get things
to be reliable
and can be done quicker?
The other was validation.
How do you validate whether
you've been successful or not?
So those are two really
important points.
And the third is--
he did mention crashing
data warehouses.
So that is definitely scary.
So bringing it all together.
So when I started
off, when I tried
to distill what Jas had
just said about especially
their approach, we talked
about deciding to move,
getting stakeholder buy-in,
identify all data sources,
POC execute.
Well, that's a start.
This is the next
steps that you're
going to take, move
historical data over, point
our sources directly
to GCP, in this case,
update your tools and
reports to point to BQ,
evaluate performance,
and benchmark it,
make sure that you're
getting identical results
across identical data
sets, and yes, turn off
on-prem EDW because that was
the goal at the beginning of it.
Keep building and
making great things.
So it's complex.
It's intense.
And I've seen this happen.
But it's doable.
I mean, prime examples, Dr.
Phil has helped a lot of people
move over.
I've seen Kohl's
move over as well.
So it's definitely doable.
It just takes effort.
So we're going to go in
a Q&A section right now.
I'm going act as the moderator.
So if you have any
questions, please
feel free to step up
to the mic, and we
can answer your questions.
MAN 1: It's not working here.
SAMRAT SAHA: Somebody
turn that mic on.
MAN 2: Plug it in?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
SAMRAT SAHA: There you go.
AUDIENCE: Yes, it works.
I have a question
for Datametica,
if I pronounced this correctly.
PHIL SHELLEY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you
address a little bit
how-- is that a static
workload migration that you do?
And how do you deal with
context information?
So for example, we've seen
a lot of query differences
that are only there because
certain data types are there
and certain
transformations need to be
applied when that is true.
So it's not always possible
to do just a query A query B
type of rewrite, but rather it
needs to be run in the context
that the original query was run.
And if you had to
do that, or if you
had to deal with that,
how many times did
you have to actually manually
go and help the system rewrite?
PHIL SHELLEY: So there's--
and you're right.
And also the data model may
need to change in some cases
because you're coming from
schemas on data warehouses
where they're not very friendly
to these big data environments.
So there may be very
high numbers of joins,
there may be concurrent
reads and writes
going on at high volumes.
So there are some
changes that have
to be done to both code and
data model and user queries
in some cases.
Now, I would say that that's
getting less and less.
The need to make changes is
going down quite quickly now
because the early days
of the cloud tools,
they were not tolerant at all of
the data structures and schemas
that were on data warehouses.
Now the BQ particularly
has advanced a lot.
So we're seeing less
and less changes
to make the same workload
move without changing
schemas in the code.
But of course, if
you want to-- if you
do want to change something,
change the formats of data,
the schemes of data, and then
maybe performance tuning,
there is a little
bit of manual work.
So it depends on-- it depends.
So sometimes it's highly
automated, sometimes
it's 25% or so manual
work and cleanup.
But it's very
workload-dependent.
But the degree of
changes we're seeing
is going down as BQ
becomes more tolerant of--
AUDIENCE: Well, I
think sometimes it's
just legacy stuff that nobody--
none of the modern
systems will implement.
So those will always
have to be dealt with.
PHIL SHELLEY: There
is some manual work.
This is not entirely automated.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PHIL SHELLEY: Another one?
Hard to see.
Somebody's coming down--
maybe two, maybe three.
George?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the presentation.
I'm curious to know about the
end user experience, the types
of tools, how many
end users did you
have to support in the
conversion, what their tool
compatibility experience was.
And then my second
question would
be, what's your experience
at estimating slot counts,
and what you thought
it would be versus what
your forecast is going to be.
JASVINDER SINGH: Yeah,
so talking about the slot
counts, so there is a
calculator that Google
has which basically
helps you look
at your current on-prem
systems and come up
with some kind of an estimate.
If we run a similar
workload in the cloud,
this is how much it will
take to run it again.
You should take that
with a grain of salt
because sometimes these numbers
are really big in some cases.
And we will-- basically we
started off with certain use
cases, and worked
with Google, and said,
if we have to do
certain workloads,
how much do you think it will
basically be on those slots?
So we started off with that.
And we started to bring
in more and more use cases
and add to those slots.
So we have not started off
with a very big number.
So we are going with
a smaller number.
And at this point,
so it's halfway
done through the migration.
I think we are trending towards
just getting to a number which
is going to add a lot of
value to our final migration
in terms of cost.
AUDIENCE: And then my
first part was about the--
I guess the end user tools
and the types of tools
that you've moved
on to the platform,
like Tableau and MicroStrategy,
and what that experience was.
Did you have to rewrite
reports to take advantage
of the new data model?
Or did they come
over more seamlessly?
JASVINDER SINGH: Yeah.
I think the approach
has been that we
don't want to just
simply lift and shift
whatever we have in the cloud--
whatever we have
on-prem because that's
going to be very difficult
to support in the longer
run because how the data
is in sixth normal form
or it's normalized in
some of our systems.
As we bring it on, we're trying
to normalize it, denormalize it
as much as we can.
And there is a change that
we are asking our partners
and business
stakeholders to make
as we are moving to the cloud.
So in terms of
tools, yes, we have
brought in some of our
reporting tools to the cloud
and making that available.
And we have also enabled a
lot of tools which will enable
self-service on the cloud.
And Dataprep is one of the
examples where we basically
provide certified data
sets to our stakeholders
and let them have it from there.
They can create
their own structures
and create the reporting that
they need eventually from that.
SAMRAT SAHA: We have time
for one more question.
PHIL SHELLEY: I was going
to say one quick question.
A lot of the newer
migrations, though,
are trying to keep the same
data model and same tools
because change management
on the human side
is the biggest issue.
So what we do is-- that
is entirely possible now.
But there's usually an
optimization phase afterwards.
Where things are
not working well,
there's some long running
queries, some issues.
So there's a tuning phase.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]